♪
>> SOME OF OUR COMPETITORS
HAVE TILTED THE FIELD A
LITTLE BIT.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
JUST TRYING TO LEVEL IT BACK
OUT.
>> FRANKLY, WE DON'T WIN BY
ASSESSING TARIFFS AND
BASICALLY COME BACK TO BITE
US.
I'M DISAPPOINTED.
>> IF YOU PUT A 10% TARIFF
ON ALUMINUM, HOW MUCH DO YOU
THINK THAT INCREASES THE
PRICE OF A SIX PACK OF BEER?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA?
A CENT.
ONE CENT.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU A
PENNY.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK IT
INCREASES THE PRICE OF AN
AUTOMOBILE IF ALL THE COSTS
ARE PASSED THROUGH?
$45.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PROBLEM
BIG PRICE EFFECTS,
NEGLIGIBLE PRICE EFFECTS.
>> THIS IS LESS ECONOMIC
POLICY AND WE HAVE TRIED IT
A WHOLE BUNCH OF TIMES OVER
THE PAST TWO CENTURIES AND
EVERY TIME AMERICAN FAMILIES
HAVE SUFFERED U.
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN QUITE A
BACK AND FORTH OVER THE LAST
DAY AND A HALF SINGS THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE IS GOING
TO INSTITUTE TARIFFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
NOT A LOT OF TALK ABOUT IT
TODAY OBVIOUSLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT A LOT OF TWEETS THIS
MORNING WHEN A COUNTRY,
U.S.A. IS LOSING MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON TRADE
WITH VIRTUALLY EVERY COUNTRY
IT DOES BUSINESS WITH TRADE
WARS ARE GOOD AND EASY TO
WIN.
FOR
EXR
EXAMPLE, WHEN WE ARE DOWN
$100 BILLION WITH A CERTAIN
COUNTRY AND THEY GET CUTE,
DON'T TRADE ANYMORE.
WE WIN BIG.
IT'S EASY.
WE MUST PROTECT OUR COUNTRY
AND OUR WORKERS.
OUR STEEL INDUSTRY IS IN BAD
SHAPE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE STEEL, YOU
DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
WHEN A COUNTRY TAXES OUR
PRODUCTS COMING IN AT SAY
50% AND WE TAX THE SAME
PRODUCT COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY AT ZERO, NOT FAIR OR
SMART.
WE WILL SOON BE STARTING
RECIPROCAL TAXES SO THAT WE
WILL CHARGE THE SAME THING
AS THEY CHARGE US.
$800 BILLION TRADE DIFFICULT
EVER DEFICIT HAVE NO CHOICE.
WE START THERE WITH OUR
PANEL.
LET'S BRING IN STEVE HAYES,
EDITOR AND CHIEF OF THE
WEEKLY STANDARD.
LESLIE MARSHALL SYNDICATED
TALK SHOW RADIO HOST AND FOX
NEWS MEDIA ANALYST HOWARD
KURTZ.
STEVE, A LOT OF PUSH BACK
FROM ALLIES WHO FEEL THIS IS
THE WRONG THING.
A LOT OF PUSH BACK FROM
CAPITOL HILL THERE ARE SOME
ALLIES OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BOTH ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
AND DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
WHO SAY THEY HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR THIS.
>> WELL, I THINK A LOT OF US
HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS
IN THE SENSE THAT THE
PRESIDENT MADE OBVIOUS
DURING THE CAMPAIGN THAT
THIS IS WHAT HE WANTED TO
DO.
SO, NOBLE SHOULD BE
PARTICULARLY SURPRISED BY
HIS ACTIONS.
I THINK WHAT IS SURPRISING
IS THE PRESIDENT'S LANGUAGE.
YOU DON'T TYPICALLY HEAR A
PRESIDENT ARGUE FOR RAISING
TARIFFS BY ANNOUNCING THAT
HE IS STARTING A TRADE WAR
AND THEN TRYING TO SPIN HIS
TRADE WAR AS A GOOD THING
FOR THE COUNTRY.
I THINK IF YOU READ WHAT THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED THIS
MORNING.
THERE IS NO POLITE WAY TO
PUT THIS.
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW
TRADE WORKS.
AND HE IS TALKING ABOUT IT
AS IF IT'S AN $800 BILLION
LOSS ON A LEDGER.
THAT'S NOT HOW TRADE WORKS.
WE HAVE GOT A LONG HISTORY
OF THIS.
GO BACK TO ADAM SMITH.
DID YOU GO BACK BEFORE.
I THINK THAT THE OTHER
PROBLEM IS THE WHITE HOUSE
DOESN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT ITS
OWN ARGUMENTS ARE ON TRADE.
YOU JUST SAW, YOU JUST
PLAYED PETER SAYING THIS WAS
ONLY $45 PER CAR TAX.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
THAT WILBUR ROSS GAVE IN A
DIFFERENT INTERVIEW TALKING
ABOUT $175 PER CAR TAX.
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THE TOTAL, IF YOU USE THE
WILBUR ROSS NUMBERS, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT 17 MILLION
VEHICLES SOLD AND CATO
INSTITUTE ESTIMATES THAT'S
ABOUT $3 BILLION TAX.
THESE ARE TAXES, THESE TAXES
WILL BE PASSED ONTO THE
AMERICAN CONSUMER.
IT WILL PROTECT THE STEEL
INDUSTRY AND IT WILL HURT
CONSUMERS MORE BROADLY.
>> Bret: HERE IS THE
COMMERCE SECRETARY ON CNBC
TODAY, WILBUR ROSS.
>> HAVE YOU GOT TO LOOK AT
THE JOB CREATION AND THE
IMPACT ON AMERICAN
EMPLOYEES.
EARN EMPLOYEES HAVE BORN THE
BRUNT OF ALL THE IMPORT
STEEL AND ALUMINUM COMING.
IN SO CORPORATE AMERICA MAY
COMPLAIN.
THE PRESIDENT IS TAKING UP
THE BANNER OF MR. AND
MRS. AMERICA.
>> Bret: LESLIE.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
WHEN I AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW, AND
SOME REPUBLICANS.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THERE IS
SOMETHING GOING ON HERE THAT
ACTUALLY MAY BE RIGHT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE UNITED
STATES ITS MANUFACTURING.
AND WITH STEEL.
WHAT WILBUR ROSS SAYS IS
RIGHT ON.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE AMERICAN
STEEL BEING USED AND BEING
PURCHASED, G.M. USES 90%
AMERICAN STEEL.
BUT THE UNITED STATES
IMPORTS MORE STEEL THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY.
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
WE DO HAVE A TRADE DEFICIT
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED.
IF YOU HAVE THESE TARIFFS IN
PLACE YOU ARE THEN PUTTING
MIDDLE CLASS WORKERS, THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO PUT THE
PRESIDENT IN HIS POSITION IN
THE OVAL OFFICE IN STATES
LIKE WISCONSIN, IN
PENNSYLVANIA, THROUGHOUT THE
RUST BELTED.
YOU ARE PUTTING THESE PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
YOU KNOW, ANOTHER THING,
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE, PEOPLE THAT
I HAVE SPOKEN TO SAY THE
STEEL THAT IS MADE IN CHINA,
WHERE WE GET A LOT OF OUR
STEEL FROM IS NOT THE
QUALITY OF THE STEEL MADE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
I DON'T KNOW BUT, BUT IF YOU
EVER BOUGHT THOSE T-SHIRTS 3
FOR 10 BUCKS THEY FALL APART
IN THE WASH AFTER ONE WASH.
I DON'T WANT TO DRIVE OVER
BRIDGES LIKE THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN
BUILDINGS LIKE THAT.
I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO
PUT AMERICA FIRST AS THE
PRESIDENT SAYS, THIS WHAT
THEY WILL A GOOD STEP.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK YOU
WILL GET MANY DEMOCRATS TO
SIGN ON.
>> I DO THINK SO.
I DO THINK SO.
>> Bret: DOMESTIC STEEL
DEMAND BISEK TORE.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN IRON AND STEEL
INSTITUTE.
YOU LOOK AT THE PERCENT
TAMMAROS, CONSTRUCTION,
AUTOMOTIVE, MACHINERY,
ENERGY.
IT ESSENTIALLY TOUCHES ALL
ASPECTS OF AMERICAN LIFE.
DOMESTIC ALUMINUM
CONSUMPTION, THERE YOU SEE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGING,
CONSTRUCTION, ELECTRICAL,
MACHINERY.
OBVIOUSLY THE BEER COMPANIES
AND THE COMPANIES THAT USE
ALUMINUM ALSO RAISING
PROBLEMS HERE.
>> YEAH, LIKE ALL TARIFFS IT
HURTS MANY INDUSTRIES, IT
HELPS A COUPLE OF
INDUSTRIES.
LOOK, DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT OTHER
COUNTRIES TAKING AMERICA TO
THE CLEANERS SINCE THE
1980s, AS PRESIDENT HE HAS
BEEN SOMEWHAT RESTRAINED BY
ACTING ON THIS LIKE BYE
PEOPLE LIKE GARY COHN THE
ECONOMIC ADVISOR.
NOW WITH THE STAFF THINNING
OUT IS HE DOING WHAT HE
WANTS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM IT'S
OVER THE OBJECTIONS WE HEARD
OVER BEN SASS.
REPUBLICANS RUN AS FREE
TRADERS.
POSITION LESLIE JUST
APPROVED IT OBVIOUSLY MORE
APPROVED OF BY DEMOCRATS.
SO IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
DONALD TRUMP BEING MORE OF
AN INDEPENDENT PRESIDENT WHO
SOMETIMES TAKES A MIDDLE
GROUND POSITION.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU CAN HOLD
UP ALUMINUM CAN AND SAY BE 1
CENT.
HEARING LOTS OF RUMBLINGS OF
RETALIATION IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
TRADE WARS MAY BE GOOD AND
FUN BUT THEY CAN COMPLICATE
AND HURT AMERICA.
BRET BREATH ON THAT ISSUE
CHRIS COX WITH THE NRA
TWEETING I HAD A GREAT
MEETING TONIGHT, THAT WAS
LAST NIGHT, WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT.
WE ALL WANT SAFE SCHOOLS,
MENTAL HEALTH REFORM AND
KEEP GUNS AWAY FROM
DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
POTUS AND VP SUPPORT.
DON'T WANT GUN CONTROL
CONTROL NRA MAGA.
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
WHAT IS DO THIS SAY?
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WILL
MOVE FORWARD, STEVE?
>> WHO KNOWS?
HONESTLY I HAVE NO IDEA.
WE TRY TO PREDICT THIS.
TALK TO PEOPLE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY TRY TO PREDICT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO SAY.
AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
HE WASN'T PLANNING ON SAYING
WHAT HE SAID YESTERDAY ABOUT
TRADE.
THIS WAS TOTALLY ADD LIBSD
AS HOWIE POINTS OUT.
THIS IS SOMETHING HE HAS
BELIEVED FOR A LONG TIME.
NOT ACCURATE FOR PEOPLE TO
SAY THIS COMES OUT OF
NOWHERE.
>> Bret: SHOCKING.
>> HE WASN'T PLANNING ON
SAYING THAT.
HE CERTAINLY WASN'T PLANNING
ON SAYING WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
GUN CONTROL AND THE MEETING,
THE BIPARTISAN MEETING THE
OTHER DAY.
HE WASN'T PLANNING, HIS
ADVISORS WEREN'T PLANNING ON
HIM EMBRACING DEMOCRATIC
TALKING POINTS ON
IMMIGRATION JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO.
HE HAS REPEATEDLY SAID OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS
THINGS THAT HAVE PLEASED
DEMOCRATS.
NOW WHETHER HE FOLLOWS
THROUGH ON THEM, WHETHER HE